the mayor of rio de janeiro in brazil
has committed to putting one percent of
their balance sheet in bitcoin that's
right another mayor somewhere in the
world absolutely capitulating and
realizing the benefits of bitcoin during
the recent rio innovation week on a
panel with the mayor of rio de janeiro
and the mayor of miami francis suarez
eduardo piez who is the mayor of rio de
janeiro decided to come out and say that
he's gonna put one percent of their
balance sheet bitcoin he also suggested
that they are studying the potential to
go ahead and allow for lower taxes if
people pay for a specific property tax
in bitcoin as well that 10 discount on
taxes if you pay it in bitcoin and so
ultimately their goal is to transform
the city into the tech capital of south
america they have about six million
people that live in the urban area of
the city they've got about 12 million
total if you include the surrounding
areas this is incredibly important
because i don't believe that even though
brazil which has over 10 inflation every
single month since september or the
housing market absolutely collapsing
because of the political instability i
don't think they're doing this for
financial gain they're not saying oh let
us just put one percent of our balance
sheet in because we think we're gonna
make money no instead what they're doing
is now adopting bitcoin has become a
signal to the world it's like a bat
signal when you say that you're adopting
bitcoin when you say that you're
plugging your city into the bitcoin
network it signals to everyone you're
serious about innovation so that you're
serious about free markets that you're
serious about actually encouraging
capitalism and economic prosperity in
your geographic region and that is what
the mayor of rio de janeiro has learned
from the mayor of miami from the
president of el salvador and many other
cities states and countries around the
world the more that you embrace bitcoin
the better it is for your local area and
of course one of the major cities in
brazil is not going to be left behind
and so we've got this quote here he said
we're going to launch crypto rio and
invest 1 of the treasury in bitcoin he
then went on to say rio de janeiro has
everything it takes to become the tech
capital of south uh south america events
like the rio innovation week come to
strengthen the city's image as the
perfect place to work live and innovate
and then we also have an outline from
the iptu which is uh or i'm sorry the
secretary of finance which is planning
uh in rio de janeiro he said we are
studying the possibility of paying taxes
with an additional discount if you pay
with bitcoin you take the discount of
the single quota seven percent it
becomes 10 if you pay in bitcoin this my
friends is the playbook for politicians
around the world whether you are a city
like miami a city like rio or you are a
state like texas florida kentucky
missouri and also wyoming here in the
united states or you're a country
something like el salvador
the playbook is very clear now
take your assets take your citizens take
your administration plug it into the
bitcoin network and you'll realize
bitcoin's good for business that's what
the mayor of rio is trying to do here
what do you guys think about this
big news
yeah a little bit right it's only one
percent uh the discount taxes is nice
but they're using the miami playbook
that mayor suarez has implemented over
the last two years to attract citizens
and bring noise um to the world from
their city right so it's it's a big news
in the grand scheme of things but um i
don't think it's gonna like shift the
narrative of bitcoin just another city
that's plugging in joe yeah i think it's
interesting i think the idea that you
can get a discount on taxes if you pay
in crypto is is cool and it's a unique
way to incentivize people want to use
that as a currency and to pay for things
in in bitcoin uh for your taxes and then
it also helps the city right because if
you're trying to
uh start to allocate some of your
position or some of your capital to or
build a position in bitcoin then it
helps when citizens start paying that
it's kind of an easy way to transfer
that in by giving them a small discount
i think ultimately it's just a small
step right in the in the grand scheme of
things um but i think seeing more
countries and and more large cities uh
introduce this philosophy really is what
i'll call it uh i think is good and
ultimately it just drives more adoption
right if suarez didn't do it then they
wouldn't do it if they don't do it then
someone else won't do it so it always
takes someone to start it it takes more
people to keep it going but eventually i
think it's a matter of time before a lot
of places do this
does this make you want to move to rio
or go visit more like what is the impact
for people who don't live there is that
really that bad signal of like hey i
think in el salvador people definitely
are going to el salvador that previously
would have never thought to go to el
salvador uh so it's a boom to tourism to
some degree is that the same thing when
it happens in a city like rio as well
yeah i mean i think that uh the the
people that are the earliest on this
train get rewarded the most right so
when you think about um what's the name
of the the restaurant in uh canada um
tahini's yeah tahini's like
they got people all over the world
looking at their stuff people interested
in it right because they operated on the
bitcoin center for a long period of time
uh el salvador has obviously benefited
tremendously miami has benefited here in
the united states other areas have
benefited but when you start to go
further out on that curve and more and
more and more and more places start to
adopt bitcoin whether it's on the
treasury or or you can pay taxes in it
or you can uh or they make it legal
tender whatever it is it becomes less
effective right so i think we're still
at the point where like yeah rio it's
interesting bitcoiners will go there
they'll uh they'll promote it they'll
say hey they'll hold the flag in there
hey this is really cool but ultimately
if 15 places do it sure 20 places 50
place 100 places it eventually becomes
less valuable if everyone is doing it
yeah it um to me i think is one it
definitely wears off over time yeah also
too is cities doing it now almost is
like yeah of course cities are going to
do this uh so like hey guess what news
flash if you're a mayor get in while
it's still hot uh but two is like it
also is less important than a nation
state right in some way actually rio has
more citizens if you include the kind of
urban area plus the surrounding areas uh
than el salvador but the nation state
was such a big shot across the bow that
uh every city now that does it is like
yeah i mean it's cool that a city did
like a nation state that you know you're
almost compared to uh the other
standards so it's uh it's interesting
because there's like four there's like
three or four things you can do as a
city or nation state right you can do
taxes you can do pay employees and
bitcoin you can let people exchange
bitcoin legally make it legal tender
like they did as well um and then you
can also just hold your assets in
bitcoin too right and doing a
combination of those things i think
generally has the same effect as doing
all of them like if you if you don't do
your taxes in bitcoin but you do all the
others it's very similar but not the
exact same thing